uh I brought you guys something because
you know I love Deadpool oh that's sweet
I know you liked it too thank you so
much
that's great
I like how your names are on the chairs
yeah so you guys know which chair to say
we're idiots yeah let's be honest this
is amazing I literally sat in that chair
and they were like oh what's wrong it
looks painful what is that correct it
looks good yeah yeah but I'm wondering
when you guys shoot those scenes what
does it look like for you on set and are
you actually doing it go ahead okay
there we go that's really interesting
Ryan seriously I'm sorry
what it's all about it's all about um
really being able to
thank you Jake oh right hey doctors
let's get it together well let's get out
of [__] town all right Google question's
gonna be like are is Ryan Reynolds High